oh my God I love you thank you you look
so great thank you you too you're all
glowy thank you congratulations on all
the things happening in your life right
now you're do you're just killing it
killing it I last time we talk it's
Christmas time last time we talked about
Christmas Villages like we decorated
have you decorated this year I'm halfway
up I my house was under renovation so
everything was in storage and they
pulled it down and I started putting my
tree together and I was like something's
missing and my team thinks I'm crazy
because I have a lot of villages a lot
of houses and I'm like something's
missing and she was like you're right my
assistant had everything pulled down and
I was like I told you the house was
missing there I know my Village me too
what did you add this year so my son
decided because we have New York we have
we have Islands we have New York and
brookin W yeah we have a Brooklyn I was
like okay I was like maybe next year
we'll add Jersey I don't know what we're
doing but he they're all the Charles
Dickens it's still the department you
know it's still that old school thing
but he but he calls them my
seven-year-old son was like oh no that's
Brooklyn I was like okay I didn't even
know you knew that yet like I didn't
even know you like what like it was but
yeah it's all set it's not we're not
final it's not final this week is
actually I'm putting the final when I
get back that's when it's all together
I'm adding a road I added a carousel a
beautiful Carousel we don't have I added
a ice skate ring we have an ice skating
ring yeah do you have the water fountain
girl what no we don't have a water
fountain I have a water fountain I don't
have a water fountain and I don't have a
carousel I have a police station and a
fire station we have police station fire
St does a car come in and out like this
shut
up I'm going to need
[Music]
picture
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home